metro police preparing for pre-pandemic
crowds on the las vegas strip on new
year's eve this despite the omicron
variant causing a surge in case numbers
hector mejia has the latest from metro
police headquarters
more than 300 000 expected on the strip
to ring in 2022 road closures on the las
vegas strip will begin at 6 p.m on new
year's eve by 8 pm the strip will be
fully closed from spring mountain down
to manila bay the pandemic is still not
over so local leaders urge everyone to
take precautions we want you to be happy
and healthy and come celebrate this
amazing city in this amazing community
there's nowhere else like this in the
world we encourage everyone to look out
for one another take personal
responsibility
and proactively take actions that help
limit the spread of kova 19 and keep
everybody safe that includes
vaccinations boosters wearing a mask
indoors and staying home if you feel
sick clark county fires says it
typically sees a surge in 9-1-1 calls
off the strip making new year's eve one
of the busiest nights of the year for
first responders county commissioner
michael naft says there are plenty of
transportation options i am begging our
community once again to make a
transportation plan before you start
your party
do not get behind the wheel of a car if
you are impaired it's that simple
starting friday night and until saturday
morning the following items are
prohibited on the strip no strollers
backpacks or glass bottles
hector mejia there with that story a